sa flotte est étanche et pourtant c'est
un appareil photo jetable vous ne
risquez plus d'abîmer votre matériel en
faisant du bateau avec sept autres
appareils jetables muni d'un
téléobjectif
finies les photos ou les personnages
sont minuscules dans le champ et voici
la photo magnétique 50 vue sur une
disquette que vous glissez dans un
appareil à 6000 francs vous pouvez
visionner instantanément les résultats
sur votre téléviseur
côté vidéo voici pour douze mille francs
la plus petite caméra 8 mm du marché 750
g vous pourrez lire les cassettes sur ce
téléviseur portatif à magnétoscope
incorporé
celui ci permet également d'enregistrer
les programmes des chaînes de télévision
son coût douze mille francs